the idea of magic and sorcery is one
that we see fairly often in Greek
mythology mostly because some of the
things that we see the gods and
goddesses do can only really be
described as magical now there are a few
minor deities that have been associated
with magic and sorcery we've already
taken a look at her karta the goddess of
magic and today we'll be examining Circe
the goddess of sorcery she was known to
the ancient Greeks as killakee but as
his common with most of the words in
ancient Greek that contained a hard case
ound
when they were latinized and anglicized
the hard case sound became a soft C and
we now refer to her as Circe she was a
daughter of Helios the titan god of the
Sun and purse one of the many oceanic
nymphs which meant that she had two
siblings passive a the wife of King
Minos and a et the guardian of the
Golden Fleece Circe appeared in a
variety of different forms sometimes she
was seen as the goddess of magic and
other times a nymph much like her mother
but the most common depiction was that
of an enchantress or sorceress she was a
goddess known for her skills in
transmutation illusion and necromancy
it's believed that Circe took residence
on the island of a a year with her many
nymph companions after being exiled by
her father there are a few explanations
as to why she was exiled the most common
being that she murdered the Prince of
Colchis who at the time was also her
husband they were very few who dare to
venture to Circe's Island as she was
capable of transforming those who
angered her into a wild beast and she
was best known for her role in Homer's
Odyssey where we see exactly what she
was capable of her mythology does
describe the island that Circe lived on
in some detail she lived in a large
house in the middle of a dense wood and
surrounded the house were numerous wild
animals lions wolves and bears but
unlike what you would expect these
animals were extremely docile and they
would prowl the surrounding grounds
greeting newcomers and guests that they
came across all of these animals were
once human but as a result of Circe's
transmutation experiments they were now
nothing more than victims of her sorcery
when Odysseus and his men reached
Circe's Island they stumbled upon her
residence and she invited them in even
throwing a feast in the name of Odysseus
and he
screw the feast contained food that they
were all familiar with piddles sweetened
of honey and laced of wine as well as
one of Circe's magical potions Circe
herself drank from an enchanted cup as
to not arouse suspicion from Odysseus's
men the men suspected nothing and gorged
themselves on the feast before them when
the men's bellies were full the magical
potion began to take effect
Circe drew her staff and with one
incantation she transformed them all
into swine only Odysseus a second in
command
Eliquis suspected treachery and had not
entered Circe's mansion well known in
what had happened to his men he escaped
and returned to the ship to warn
Odysseus in the rest of the crew had
elected to stay behind
Odysseus took the men that he had left
at his disposal and set out to rescue
his crew but before he entered Circe's
woods he was intercepted by Hermes who
had a message from Athena she advised
the dish's to use a specific herb to
protect himself from the sorcery that
his men had fallen victim to when
Odysseus eventually confronted Circe he
was able to resist her sorcery
Circe then attempted to seduce Odysseus
luring him to her bed
Hermes had previously advised that he be
cautious of such a thing as she would
attempt to take his manhood unless he
had her swear by the name of the gods
that she would not odysseus eventually
freed his men and they remained on the
island for a year or so feast and and
rested for the next voyage Homer's
Odyssey doesn't redevelop the
relationship between Cersei and Odysseus
after their confrontation but we can
assume that they at least remained civil
with Circe allowing Odysseus and his men
to remain on her island even advising
Odysseus on what routes he should take
on his next voyages now if we take a
look at Hesiod's Theogony it does state
that Circe bought a three sons of
Odysseus a Deus latinus and telegonus
who would set sail to find his father
when Cersei informed him of who he was
she gave to Legolas a poisonous spear
that he would unknowingly kill his
father with and along with this is his
other son Telemachus whose mother was
Penelope they brought a dish as his
corpse to Cersei who were the use of
some magical herbs and sorcery was able
to bring Odysseus back from the dead the
heroes so grateful that he gave his son
Telemachus to Circe's daughter
phanie in marriage but like many stories
in Greek mythology this one would end in
tragedy
Telemachus would one day have a very
heated discussion with his mother-in-law
which would end in him killing Cersei
kiss F&E with an avenge her mother by
killing Telemachus and upon hearing the
news of his son's death Odysseus would
die from grief so I guess the next time
you consider your own family to be
dysfunctional you can consider yourself
lucky that you're not Telemachus who
watched his own father die only to be
resurrected and forced him to marry his
ex-lovers daughter whose mother he would
eventually kill causing his wife to then
kill him and his father to die from
grief whatever you choose to take from a
story of Cersei and Odysseus there's no
doubt that it's a thoroughly
entertaining and eventful story
Cersei much like her karta was a minor
goddess in Greek mythology and her
association with magic and sorcery meant
that she was later associated with
witchcraft when that notion came into
existence the scientific interpretations
of Cersei show her to be somewhat of a
botanist using plants and herbs that
were caused amnesia hallucinations
delusions and ultimately death sir
Caesar got a son I'm fairly undecided on
she doesn't come across as particularly
caring or even patient anyone who
disturbed her work or angered her was
immediately punished by being turned
into an animal what suddenly does come
across is her devotion to her work
I see Cersei as somewhat of a tinkerer
experimenting with different potions and
herbs
to what end I'm not exactly sure of but
power and knowledge are most likely what
she was driven by she does happen to
have many of the tropes that we were
associated with witches the power of
magic a collection of animal familiars
and a house in the woods of the forest
but I'd like to know how you guys feel
about Cersei do you feel she harbored
any resentment towards her father and
the gods for exile in her or do you
think she didn't really care do you see
her as a sorceress or a witch or perhaps
maybe a slightly all tempered botanist
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained